welcome to water's world i'm jesse
waters corruption's killing our country
that's the subject of tonight's waters
words joe biden limped to virginia this
week to stump for democrat governor
terry mcauliffe it was a catastrophe out
of the gate joe biden praised virginia's
current governor ralph northam a
democrat who got caught rocking
blackface
remember when that photo broke joe biden
buried him but a year later biden
appreciates his pal governor blackface
first of all goes without saying how
much i appreciate your current governor
ralph
norton where's ralph there you are pal
thank you
the corrupt media didn't even touch it
blacked out biden endorsing governor
blackface got to keep virginia blue
then biden decides to go full cnn you
never go full cnn
talks about trump the entire time
i ran against donald trump
[Music]
and terry is running against an acolyte
of donald trump donald trump donald
trump trump donald trump is there a
problem with trump being here
is he embarrassed
donald trump isn't running for governor
of virginia
but that sleepy strategy dump on trump
that's all he's got
but then a funny thing happened a wee
love trump chant broke out
[Music]
[Applause]
that's all right let him go
let him go that's okay
that's all right
why don't you hang out and talk to me
after this is over okay
the media spiked that too
and they juiced the crowd numbers
reporting 2500 in attendance now water's
world fact checked it nowhere near that
count didn't even crack a thousand we're
estimating around 800 people showed up
800 people to see the president of the
united states in a blue state that he
won by double digits
something doesn't add up and we all know
what it is
the whole thing was cringe like terry
dancing
nobody wants to see that he's worse than
elaine from seinfeld
in another speech in jersey this week
joe biden raps
coughs into his hand and then starts
shaking other people's hands
media silent
no masks media dead silent
but make sure you have to mask your
six-year-old
the whole thing's a fraud it's like the
emperor with no clothes the democrats in
the media are afraid to say this guy's
got no clothes on because if they call
him out his entire presidency collapses
so everybody sits around pretending that
this is normal like they don't see
anything pretending they don't see how
nuts this is
biden and the democrats don't see how
awkward this is they take this silence
as a license to steal
because they're not being called out for
anything
they can get away with everything that's
what they think and they are
hunter biden's paintings are valued at a
half a million dollars
that's more than a sign picasso's worth
hunter and joe share a secret bank
account and hunter's associates do joe's
taxes
is anybody paying attention here
our attorney general's family is getting
rich off critical race theory in schools
merrick garland's daughter married a
dude who's making millions pushing crt
in virginia so the dad garland uses the
fbi to silence parents who don't want
crt
angry parents are now the new domestic
terrorists
the attorney general is using the fbi
for profit
ted cruz called him out and he
stonewalled
if critical race theory is taught in
more schools does your son-in-law make
more money yes or no this memorandum has
nothing to do with critical race will
you answer if you started any kind of
curriculum will you answer if you saw it
i am answering the best i can yes or no
did you seek an ethics opinion this
memorandum has did you seek an ethics
opinion this memorandum has nothing to
do with general are you refusing to
answer if you sought an ethics i'm
telling you that there's no possible so
you're saying no just answer it directly
you know how to answer a question
directly
of course she won't answer a question
he's above the law he doesn't even need
to know a ninth grader was raped in a
gender fluid virginia school bathroom by
a boy wearing a skirt he doesn't need to
know the superintendent covered it up
garland and the democrats just want
critical race theory rammed down our
family's throats
the washington post the worst newspaper
in america wrote
parents claim they have the right to
shape their kids school curriculum
they don't
joseph stalin famously said education is
a weapon whose effect depends on who
holds it in his hands and at whom it is
aimed
see public schools have become a weapon
straight out of the communist playbook
that's another reason why they're
pushing free college free pre-k and free
day care in biden's welfare bill
guess what else they slipped into the
biden welfare bill
hundreds of thousands more green cards
all backed by big tech like facebook and
microsoft
silicon valley doesn't want to hire
american they want to hire foreign
nationals on the cheap
the government's supposed to be working
for us but no they're working for big
tech instead
politicians save companies on labor
costs and then the companies send those
savings back to politicians in the form
of donations
that's the game
but bernie sanders wrote the bill isn't
bernie supposed to be against this kind
of thing it used to be
the middle class in this country
continues to shrink i don't know why we
need millions
of people to be coming into this country
as guest workers who will work for lower
wages than american workers and drive
wages down even lower than they are
right now where did that bernie go
sanders is just another corporate
sellout but with better branding totally
corrupt
biden has no respect for american
workers either despite his little lunch
pail persona
while the working man's wages are
getting grinded into dust by inflation
and illegal workers biden killed the
wall
there will not be another foot of wall
constructed in my administration
it's costing taxpayers 5 million a day
not to finish the border wall it just
sits there rotting
while illegals scooch through the open
holes
but taxpayers are footing the bill for a
new wall
but not on the border
around president joe biden's delaware
beach house
almost a half a million coming out of
your pockets for biden to have his own
wall
it's sickening isn't it
politicians protecting their own homes
with your money
but leaving your home and country wide
open to caravans
joe says he has nothing to do with the
caravans coming into the country
but that's not what they say
why now
the best time
because of the administration
because of joe biden
biden hasn't even been to the border
he hasn't visited a jammed up port
either but
biden had time to unveil a first ever
national gender strategy
nobody even knows what that means it's
gibberish
we did find out biden's strategy for
getting americans out of afghanistan
though
a smoking gun email released shows biden
ordered the planes out of afghanistan to
be filled to excess
with refugees not caring if they weren't
vetted just fill them up and bring them
over so the planes look packed for the
cameras
there's even another hostage crisis
besides afghanistan haitian bandits took
16 u.s citizens hostage
joe biden hasn't even mentioned it
just a few miles off our shores and they
sit there languishing
media covered up two
hostage crises
it's got to be hard to be that corrupt
these countries take americans hostage
and we give their people amnesty
now an afghan evacuee was just charged
with raping a woman in montana
biden flew back afghan rapists but
stranded americans
the metoo media didn't get around to
covering that did they
but hillary's flak huma abedin says a
senator once made a pass at her
i did go back to a senator's apartment a
senator who i knew and i was very
comfortable with and he kissed me in a
very um
shocking way are you suggesting that
that senator assaulted you
i'm suggesting that i was in an
uncomfortable situation
with
i was in an uncomfortable situation with
a senator and i didn't know how to deal
with it
more media cover this than the ninth
grade transgender bathroom rape and the
afghan evacuee rape in montana
but a senator going in for a kiss with
crookeds consigliere front page news
u.s senators worry about who else an
unnamed senator may have sexually abused
sexually abused
meanwhile a senator who we will name
republican richard burr from north
carolina sold a bunch of stock right
after he got a secret intel briefing on
the coming coronavirus last year
has he been charged
he called his brother right after and
then his brother called his broker and
sold a bunch of stock also
his brother hasn't been charged
insider trading must be legal for
politicians but they want the irs to
look at your bank account if it has over
600 bucks in it
washington's corrupt to the bone the
voters are getting hoes but biden's just
throwing it in our face just how lazy it
is
he's logged in more personal travel days
than any other modern president
out of the first 276 days of his
presidency he spent 108 of them either
vacationing or working from his delaware
homes or from camp david more than trump
obama bush all of them
the politicians keep raiding the
treasury the fed keeps buying the debt
the dollar gets destroyed pushing oil
prices higher and the fuel costs are
passed down to the consumer whose wages
are eaten up by inflation and open
borders
wages wasted on empty shelves since
everything's made in china a communist
country that just sprung a killer virus
on us
but we can't criticize because they're
in bed with our wicked media and tech
giants
who will cancel you for coming too close
to the truth
blatant corruption is staring us right
in the face
are your eyes open yet
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else